we got a guest David so and you know
you're a you're a hit on my podcast
you're a very talented young man thank
you i I just let me just okay and when I
heard that you were doing my podcast
again our pocket excuse me I can just no
excuse me love it our podcast I was
really excited welcome back give him a
round of applause
[Laughter]
what's up what's going on nothing
chilling man yeah what's going on since
we last saw you
oh that film that I talked to you about
got in Sundance ooh yeah got into
Sundance won the next audience award oh
you go yes I did
I saw [ __ ] I can't remember Redemption
no no no it's Susan Sarandon
Hubbs Andy Dufresne yeah yeah listen I
know the actor's name I know I know it
but we're not gonna way moving on okay
till you figured that [ __ ] I just know
him from Sonic I call him mr. Shawshank
I know you're a movie you know yo yo yo
yo you you don't you do dude you walked
up to him and said what's up mr. Shah
know what I did was I saw him and when I
glimpse by him I trying to touch his
shoulder yeah and I just grazed it back
but it just registered very weird so I
went swipe he turned around I chickened
out and I walked the other way see the
movie you saw your movie no I doubt it
oh I just saw him walk by there was a
lot of celebrities just walking by whoa
it was pretty awesome
that's cool right yeah felt good huh it
felt good to see them yes pretty awesome
for me anyways I don't know I don't
really go outside so I know like a lot
of you know when people see like
celebrities they freak the [ __ ] out but
it's usually like people I've seen in my
childhood yeah and then when I see it I
figure out like when I first met you
amazing experience yes thank you
awesome one time what
was your using drugs and partying I am I
will I woke up in Vince Vaughn's house
and um they were he goes we're playing
charades I swear I [ __ ] I swear to
[ __ ] god
I played charades with I swear to
[ __ ] god Ashley Judd Oh John farver
oh my friend I'm ed was there me a
couple of other guys and it was I I was
so scared because I was like I was so
drugged out what do you want oh she's
taking like 60 Vikings a day yeah I mean
I was like just really yeah yeah some
weed maybe 60 bucks is what I was using
yes it's a real surreal and then you try
to act cool but in your head you're like
holy [ __ ] it's all these people you know
man
right is that what happened is there a
celebrity that you could who in your
head would you freak out over I actually
that sudden I met me along [ __ ]
second time I did that [ __ ] I did that
also with Tatiana ollie
yes I helped a man and then I was like
I'm a really big fan of you like I loved
your music and including when you were
in Fresh Prince yeah and I was always
supposed to let go overhand but I kept
talking to her just like this are
subsets of steps up
just keep that hand there yes look at
that tom what about it what are you
doing with that thumb the grip thumb
yeah you're putting it in their hand oh
man why won't you show you the strength
because I didn't know and then literally
my manager walks up pay just prize my
hands yeah because you're my dog went
crazy when you walk in the house you I I
realized you're a [ __ ] mutant no you
are you're not there's nothing on earth
that even resembles you know your dog a
nicer when it was you wobble wobble
would I walk walking sleep so how did so
winners go come out uh-huh
we're gonna do a LA premiere in April
29th on the anniversary of the riot
are we invited yes everybody you know
what that doesn't feel special everybody
because now now it's gonna be like a
trump rally signs of stuff so I'm now
going now at Google well if it's very
specific like we get a nice invitation
and it's us John Cho anyway sorry oh no
that was crossing the line
[Music]